joining us here in person in studio
great to see you sir big fan of yours
from back in the day on the wire orange
is the new black and now halo available
for streaming today on paramount plus
the man who plays the role of master
in the richardson good to see you sir
the master chef yeah you are here good
to see you man yeah nice to see you
thank you for having me i mean probably
master chief pardon me no no it's uh
you're like
i really say that you're not the first
master chief my bad good to see you
thank you thank you um by the way uh the
success of this show was apparent by the
fact that i was in
sofie stadium
watching the end of the afc championship
game
between the chiefs and the bengals on
the big screen yep and what was trending
on my phone wasn't just the game right
but the trailer that debuted in the afc
championship game
for halo yeah they did a big a big
activation in that game it was awesome
unfortunately the schedule didn't quite
work out because i wanted it to be for
the the chiefs and bills the week before
now that would have been huge you know
that was a game oh my god no doubt about
that but the uh the the um the trailer
racked up five million views in just a
couple of days
couple things is how heavy is that what
you're wearing uh about 55 pounds uh but
it's not the weight really it's actually
uh the fact that you can't lift your
arms above your head okay
it makes you a little bit immobile
that's that's the challenge of that
thing uh but we're working on it for
second season we're it's a great great
costume studio actually fbfx studios out
of london one of the best they made it
for the martian they did they've done
the suits for like so many great shows
um and they do a great job with it so so
we're working on it modifying it okay so
i guess i am mandated to ask you if you
played halo back in the day yeah yeah
i've answered that question a few times
over the last couple weeks i bet you
yeah uh you know i did i played in high
school i didn't grow up with tv and and
or video games uh i grew up in rural
british columbia and canadian rocky
mountains okay so without entertainment
i grew up with trees
[Laughter]
so good old-fashioned nature outdoors
entertainment yeah yeah yeah yeah go
outside and entertain yourself this
exactly use your imagination
that's why i'm here uh so so you know um
didn't have any of that stuff so then i
went to high school moved to seattle and
high for high school and my folks split
up and my dad finally got a tv
uh i would go to my friend's houses and
play some halo after school that was my
first introduction to it yeah but i only
played uh versus mode i never played it
as the story like campaign mode sure so
i had no concept of it as a story game
sure and so as soon as i got the job
which was 2018 my first mission was
obviously to go learn about everything
halo and right and digest all the
mythology and i was like immediately
just
overwhelmed and blown away by the extent
of what's been established over 20 years
and it's not just the six mainline games
right it's the novels the animated
shorts the
um
that just through multiple media sources
they've established this like really
rich and beautiful mythology and then
have a so a passionate fan base already
locked in that's very that's part of the
reason why a show gets picked up for a
second season before the first one even
starts to stream first time i've been
involved with the show that got picked
up before we aired congratulations on
that and so um have you already gotten
the sense
of the because when you're passionate
fan bases they are so locked in on
what's
real or what's close to hewing to the
their experiences i don't know if you've
gotten that yet well what's interesting
you know is this
the master chief or master chef
depending on what no no i was going to
bring my chef i appreciate it
my glasses are all jacked up i should
know anyway coming in no no no no i'm
not giving you a hard time he
the character is hugely iconic right
never takes his helmet off in the games
because you're meant to be him when you
play right so if you lose the helmet and
show the face you blow the illusion that
you're the guy so a huge part of our
show is exploring
the dynamic and the tension between
master chief the soldier and john the
human so we're taking the helmet off you
know that's been this sort of
controversial thing right is the fan
base is like you can't do it because
you're gonna blow this thing
but
what has been
overwhelmingly amazing to feel today
is
all these people that were so upset that
the helmet was coming off
um
are now saying how wonderful it is and
how how they're on board with it and and
you know so far knock on wood i'll keep
my fingers crossed all that the fan base
seems to be extremely satisfied with
with what we're doing which which is a
huge huge huge blessing for us and and
um and we're very happy about that
congratulations on that pablo schreiber
here on the rich eisen show so how does
somebody who grows up in british
columbia yeah with uh no entertainment
as you just pointed out how does that
person start to be a fan of the new york
jets how the hell does that happen pablo
schreiber wow
so i went to college i went to carnegie
mellon university there you go yeah i
know you know
joe manganello
classmates
me joe and matt bomer
we're all in the same class does that
mean you also play dungeons and dragons
too i don't
i don't
i should have though growing up in
british columbia and i'm only having
trees for friends but i just don't know
if
if manganella's your guy i mean like he
would he's he never he never roped me
into the dungeons and dragons i've
always been a little skeptical and uh
and yeah he never he
he's giving him a side eye like
he never got me he never got me in
careful he never got me in probably you
spent any time at the o in oakland back
then um have i been to oakland i know
have you spent any time at the o in
oakland when you went to cmu
no
no
no not so much okay not so much oh the
oh the the original dining hall yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm on
forbes avenue yeah absolutely absolutely
and um there we had this amazing little
bar right on forbes this was so
it's so hard to remember that place
that was in 2000 i graduated but i
immediately moved to new york that was
that was where this story was going okay
and it was uh you know here i am a new a
new kid coming to new york and it was a
choice between the giants and the jets
and this was two thousand two thousand
vinnie vinnie testaverde was quarterback
yes parcells had just i think uh oh he
was going he was gone he was gone right
but not too long
uh not too long what you're saying is
you you heard the clarion call of wayne
corbett and found it too irresistible
what i'm saying is i found the jets the
giants boring
i didn't like their uniforms they were
like too well behaved wasn't enough
drama corporate to corporate corporate
you know what i mean not a corporate man
and i'm not a corporate guy at all i'm a
guy who likes a loser
i'm a guy
who likes to suffer for my art
and my sports teams
richard you know what i mean
yes i do know i had it good early i got
i got on the jets bandwidth there was
like you know four or five years there
where we were mediocre right the herm
edwards years they yeah they smoked
peyton manning in the playoffs one year
couldn't couldn't quite get it going
just enough sort of like if you ever if
you ever play golf you birdie 18 after
having a tough 17 holes it keeps you
going and then sexy rexy came in
like a like a 300 pounds of just
just sex
and uh
you know afc championship two years in a
row i know it was great and then wonder
years and then and
and
then
and then everything else and then uh
then not so much yeah butt fumble green
is the new black yeah
oh my gosh so anyway and yeah that
wasn't yesterday yesterday was like the
epitome of being justified it was the
ultimate experience of being a jets fan
not only yes
do the dolphin sign one of the greatest
players in the nfl yes
which alone would be like okay the
dolphins are getting the guy right right
the only team in the division that maybe
we could beat
they're going to get the best receiver
yes
10 minutes before they get the best
receiver it's rumored
maybe we're going to get the best
receiver correct it's us or the dolphins
yes yeah so there's 10 minutes of like
yes tyrique's coming yeah
no
well i it's almost as if you you you
wished you didn't know you were in on it
you know that's what i'm saying correct
like to know that they were in on it and
then he chose the dolphins over
new york but i will just say this i will
counsel you to say yeah that i like the
general manager yeah that he did what he
had to do you don't want to give up
the fourth or the tenth overall pick
he was going to give up two seconds for
him and that's it and like that's what's
gonna happen and and uh he didn't go
overboard and then i just don't know if
the jets were ready to get tyreek hill
and like it just i think you're right
they get a slow climb here and build
smart like the reason why the jets also
got into trouble published right here on
the rich islands
is they spent on like
players that are out you know
outside like the safety and jamal adams
in the back or you don't spend out here
mm-hmm
get that back at the running back get
the line straight and let's go to work
like that's what you got to do let's do
it i'm i'm a big supporter of this
regime douglas okay saleh okay i'm still
on board i'm still on board you know so
so let's see where it goes obviously
wilson is the big question mark so what
is it like then uh
when the jets disappoint and then you
turn on a television set and hear your
half brother do the the voice over for
it you know
the the tracks of the misery is liab
well he's into suffering too you know
it's just
that's what we do damn it man i mean
just like he's just like
just someone unfamiliar actually do the
voice over work i know i don't know
exactly yeah for a while there he was
infinity so i was like oh great you got
like all the fancy cars and all and all
the football teams like can you leave
something for me that's a hard knock
that's a very hard knock but hey i'd
like to see him play master chef yes
you know what i don't know it by the way
pablo
tell him tell him tell him what's gonna
happen what's gonna happen tell them
what's going to happen chris i'm going
to talk about it i'm going to tell you
what's going to happen yeah please this
is going to haunt rich for at least the
rest of the month eat mel i've longer
than that he is going to eat at him
through the springtime into the summer
it feels like it feels like a story that
you tell to a guy to make him feel
better and i'll absorb it i'll listen to
it i think by tomorrow he's done
i think by tomorrow it's gone no we've
just met we've just met we've just met
no no no
if i have anything to say about it he
won't because burn a hole
sometime in the next few days you should
be receiving at this address a beautiful
chef oh my god
i'm all if there's somebody is in the
green room right now already placing the
order
and it will be arriving here shortly
well it's amazing this is like the step
brothers gif we just became best friends
let's talk about the wire
by the way thank you lis can i give you
some props real quick sure after busting
your balls yes
thank you for talking about fredo
okay yeah for the godfather yeah okay
that's your favorite godfather garage i
mean come on well because of john cazal
and as you mentioned the five movies
all nominated for best picture right
only movies he ever appeared in his life
right that's it like how do you have
that career that's just insane and and
it's tough to figure out which one he
was the best in i guess you could say he
you they're all they're all good right
and he doesn't he doesn't steal any of
them like that's that's an actor right
he disappears into everything he did and
was perfect for every role how amazing
so thank you for saying no i appreciate
you saying that and uh but it's still
guys got good taste i thank you i
appreciate that i appreciate that and
you and the wire man
uh season two of the wire it was a
fascinating season because for fans of
the show
to
have this show come back and then
it was the first time that you you saw
that it was going to be similar same
characters same town but totally
different storyline essentially just a
handful would be clearly a through line
from season one to season two open
sequence is different the music was
different
and
and it was on the docks it was on the
docks what was that like for you as an
actor to come into that show after
season one and then be part of a
such a groundbreaking season of
television well so so many things going
on there right because it was it was my
first tv job so i was coming out of
college like
let's have let's do some acting
got cast on this show and it's hbo like
okay i mean they're there and it was the
beginning of hbo so it wasn't like what
they are now you know what i mean
it's uh so it had some prestige but i
watched the first season and i was like
wow
it's cool
but the production value felt kind of
low
you know the writing was clearly super
high-end yes interesting
but it it wasn't a hit you know it was a
small little tv show that that was
exploring really interesting ideas uh
for me what was so fascinating already
is like talking about um
the causes of poverty in this country
right through the lens of one single
city
um
so but but it was it was very small at
that point and it was it hadn't expanded
at all as you said into what it was
going to become so i was just i was like
okay um
just trying to make the most of an
opportunity really right
my first day of work uh i slept through
my alarm oh
man got stopped by the police and got a
speeding ticket on my way to work
was three hours late
to my first day of work
david simon comes into the trailer i'm
about to ask you exactly what did he say
on nick's bacha's first day on set yes
and he said
don't worry about it son
just come out and do your part
and walked away and
those were probably the most words he
spoke to me the whole season
[Laughter]
maybe because i was three hours late
on my first day wow um
but you know the
obviously for that to be
my first job
uh
so huge in establishing
for me the bar of what was you know what
what to expect right
i got spoiled for sure early on but so
much of what i've taken with me through
my career was established
in that season of television right
putting material first
writing is always always leads
always
um set two alarms set two alarms
have a backup plan yes
oh man it was a flip phone just didn't
just didn't work
um and and you know alexa fogle who cast
me in that is one of the great casting
directors in the industry still
um so grateful to her for that and what
a cast and what a cast you know from top
to bottom and again like john cazale you
know a whole bunch of people not not
looking to take focus right take it
everybody just falling into their role
and doing their part
um so
uh still feel so lucky to to have been a
part of that right i mean um
dominic west and uh also idris elba yeah
i don't know how many will you michael k
williams may he rest in peace you know
uh omar
i have an omar common t-shirt i mean
that is a
it is just an incredible show and that
was right when i think the sopranos was
obviously the big show yeah on hbo yes
sopranos was the popular one ryer was
like the little brother that nobody
really watched that kept on going and
had and had
even more of a sprawling cast i mean the
number of characters that would be on
that program yeah i can't say enough
about the wire it's truly one of my
favorite shows of all time yeah yeah
thank you such an honor to be part of it
i'm i'm still
uh in awe of david
really and what he did you know right to
to create that thing and and have all of
those five seasons
be so different and so interesting and
and investigate as i said those like
causes of poverty through so many
different angles in one city it's just
like
just the most beautiful canvas and if
anybody's uh also just a fan of david
simon's writing and wants to see it on a
daily basis just follow him on twitter
for just five minutes
see what that one's like yeah oh my god
some of the most colorful language it
can be a little surly 280 characters
it's a block party no doubt about that
and then orange is the new black how was
that experience for you
um that was amazing uh another weird one
where uh you know
it was netflix so at the very beginning
of netflix
i had this interesting history of like
catching these services right at the
beginning right
it was their first show well uh uh the
kevin spacey one came first right house
of cards house of cards right and we
were right after that correct
and and the house of cards hadn't been
released so it was we were making them
they were going to come out first we
were making this tiny little show about
women's prison right women in prison yes
women of all different types and sizes
and colors right at the time now it's
like oh yeah that's what tv is right but
at the time it was like who's going to
watch this
this is this is not
is there going to be an audience for
this
but i think a lot of people as we were
making it we're feeling that like that's
cool like let's let's make it and see
what happens but um
and i was in an interesting part of my
career too i had i had had two kids at
that point had uh done a couple of
network shows
and was really in this place where you
know to pay the bills or whatever i was
like the guy from the wire man i started
my career on the wires and now now
right before orange the new black i had
been fired from a cbs pilot
uh
that went to series without me
and it was i won't i won't name any
names but it was not great you know and
i was the guy
from this great television show who was
now getting fired from cbs procedurals
that were not great
and uh
and orange is a new black i i just kind
of genji i had done weeds with her yes
and
she called me up and was like i got this
little part on on this uh
women's tv show um would you come in and
try on a mustache for me and see if it
works
i was like yeah i'll try on a mustache
genji sure
we tried it it worked and uh
i'll be honest very creepy yeah of
course listen i'll be honest that was
that was the point that was the whole
point yeah and uh and and the hair it
wasn't just the mustache with the hair
the whole thing i walked in i was like
give me the dolph lundgren cut from
rocky iv
right and they were like easy done
she's a vibe with a porn stash boom
uh and you know and the rest is history
obviously that show became hugely
successful and um
and
and exceeded everybody's expectations
and kind of hit and so that was like the
second building block for me yeah to
kind of move forward and and get to have
a bit of a another chance and on
paramount plus which is not if i'm not
mistaken a very cbs centric uh
organization in a way too it is and also
how about this a sort of new streaming
service
just about to build and uh take off
that's what you do for a living man
i make streaming services you do you
make
you make dreams come true
you make them come true you're welcome
hbo and netflix and paramount
guys i'm here for you you are indeed
you are indeed
so what do you want to tell fans of halo
what do you want what can you tell them
what can you want to what do you want to
oh man come on come on over and check it
out because uh i think for for hardcore
fans of the game it's going to feel like
a very uh familiar universe you know
that they loved and and and played in
for so long and they get to experience
it in a completely different way because
of the nature of the medium you know
what i mean it's not it's not a first
person shooter it's a long-form
television series and through the
process of a long-form television series
we're gonna get to know this character
in a way that you never did in the game
and and hopefully that'll be rewarding
for people uh and i think it will be
rewarding for
for new fans as well and that's one
thing i'm really excited about is
because i fell in love with with all the
halo mythology over the last three years
learning about it so now to get to
expose it to a whole new group of people
and show
them why we love this universe so much
is really part of the thrilling thing
for me
so congrats yeah thank you so much
congrats on it and uh you got a good
manganello story you want to hose him on
before
absolutely i do
how about this one okay
drama school
sophomore year
carnegie mellon carnegie mellon
pittsburgh p joe was always a very
intense guy
you know he wanted he wanted to take his
scenes to the fullest okay
really wanted to lose himself and in his
scenes kind of still is like that i
think a little bit
i was i was describing it as something
that might feel familiar if you know the
guy okay very good yeah so sophomore
year he he plays a character uh i don't
remember why he had this instinct
but he decided that
he was gonna knock one of his teeth out
huh what what what do you mean he's
gonna knock one of his teeth ask him
about this
for a scene like what is he playing he
wanted to have a tooth knocked out for
his scene
he wanted to have a missing front tooth
so makeup wasn't good enough for him or
i don't know it's college he chipped his
tooth
and it wasn't just like a little nick
like he what'd he do did he i don't i
actually don't know how he did it i
don't know if it was a that's like let's
get that part of the story
uh because he knocked out his front
tooth wow all right let's facetime joe
right now
get him on the phone
my goodness do we facetime i just want
to call him up it felt a little bit like
that lawrence olivier dustin hoffman
story you know it's like just act
try exactly
yeah for people who don't know what's on
store again what is that oh uh so
marathon man oh i see what you're saying
yeah yeah lawrence olivier dustin it's
the most famous acting story dustin
hoffman being like the new guard of
method actors right and he's running
around outside huffing and puffing
uh slept in the
gutter or something like this and comes
to do this scene where olivier is
pulling his two yes indeed right is it
is it safe is it safe right and uh and
dustin hoffman is doing his method
acting thing and olivier looks over at
him and he says
have you ever tried acting
fantastic
all right pablo schreiber everybody
thank you for being on this program i
can't wait to see more of you as the
master chief
oh and halo nailed it dude nailed it i
am just literally not going to work
tomorrow
oh you're coming to work you're lying
from back in the day rich broiling in
your own sweat that's me
pablo on twitter at official pablo
shriver on instagram check out halo
starting to stream it today exclusively
on perimeter it's on get on there
paramount plus i would say you know like
donkey kong but that's just it's a
different type of video
okay mike i got it you used to play halo
you were good
do you have to run do you have to run
i'm here
let's say right start right where you
are we'll finish up the show with pablo
shriver in a moment he's so dying to
tell you his halo story
yes you are mike you're you're in it now
buddy there's no getting out then we'll
see if we can get manganella on the
phone
do you want to fill timeline
telling pablo schreiber you're you're
you're you're halo
a player in-depth like kind of game i
know we just had an interview about it i
know and i'm explaining this you didn't
play it that's what i was saying because
you didn't play rich
did i betray that by calling a
masterchef
it's weird you're right when you see
that like when you guys like talk and
stuff yeah because you're not used to
that in the game yeah the helmet's
always on tell him your story
so
i played halo with my best friend rob
who i've known for 35 years moved out
from new jersey with me years ago but we
played the first one
like
i like he's like you got to play this
game we played it in like a day
and a half we were probably up 20 hours
the second game the day came out we got
it and played it i could see the fan
base now when you see this in like real
life it's got it's insane it's like
because you're used to that game yeah
like everything that they did and the
master chief who's like there the whole
time with you because he kind of trained
him and you're him well in the beginning
in the training i'm saying before
because you work with another but you're
the master chief the whole time and when
you play with another guy the game is
like that i i'm actually gonna i wasn't
like and i say this i wasn't like a fan
after uh of the halo after like the i
think we played it on like three or four
is this good for you or is it are you
are you fine right now
this is a great story okay but this i
will watch i'm like with james khan
after like the third or fourth one
because i worked so much that i want to
watch this really bad now because that's
that makes me happy to hear that because
it looks amazing yeah it looks yeah the
the visuals are pretty stunning you
follow the game play like the way it was
like today follow the way the game
no the storyline doesn't follow it's
it's set in the universe and and there
will be things that will intersect and
you know come through but it doesn't
follow the exact plot of the game but
it's amazing yeah pablo you know what
else you were in that i really loved was
lights out oh yeah one season
it just didn't get i wanted anything but
that show was great i love that show
yeah little boxing show i always thought
we should have been making an mma show
okay and the uh the
show runner at the time warren light
he and i were talking a lot and so the i
was the younger brother of the
heavyweight champion of the world in the
boxing world yeah and i the next season
we were going to go into mma and i was
going to he was i was going to go
forward as the mma fighter oh okay but
we didn't get to do it yeah i was a big
fan of that show man is do we have our
is the caller on the phone line right
he's on the phone okay joe manganiello
are you there i i'm here
okay we're live on the rich eisen show
remember the old show this is your life
remember that show where where where you
have to tell uh see if you recognize a
voice from the past sure okay uh my
in-studio guest live on the rich eisen
show uh do you want to say something to
see if he guesses who you are
have you ever played a chicken
have you ever been an actor playing a
chicken at a county fair
you you you bet your ass
[Laughter]
do you want to guess who this is joe oh
man i mean okay so what you're referring
to is this
uh little scene i did from a play called
coco van as part of my carnegie mellon
showcase yes so you're getting there
you're getting there in new york and in
l.a okay um
it's a male voice man i need him to keep
talking more
can i get another clue
yeah did you ever
in sophomore year
take a scene so far
that you decided to remove your own
tooth joe manganiello that's right that
was freshman year yeah freshman year
yeah lady breeze i shaved my head bald
and pulled my my tooth out with a loaf
of french bread
we were wondering how you did it this
was the reason for the call we needed to
know how you got the 2000 because i
forgot that part of the story so so i
got hit in the face with a baseball bat
when i was nine
and uh this part i didn't know yeah and
i'm missing two out of four of my front
teeth they just blasted in half
um and i forgot this and so yeah i i i
don't know the character kept
complaining about how he had his tooth
chipped and
he played frankenstein live on stage
with his play called lady breeze by john
guerrer
he was kind of crazy so i i just you
know i was like oh i was playing
frankenstein it's an animated corpse i
you know probably had to be operated on
in the head you know so i i'll shave my
head bald
and then i was like i have chipped teeth
i'll just get a oh yeah like i'll get a
loaf of french bread just start working
that thing out and then pop and um the
problem was i didn't looking back i
should have told
the actors i was acting with ahead of
time that i was gonna go through such a
radical transformation because
the scene starts out and this girl was
on stage doing a monologue and i i come
out from behind the risers
and and i you know i i was back there i
had probably super poly grip with my
tooth in so nobody would know and i wore
a ski cap so nobody would see that my
head was bald so i came out you know
bald headed no teeth
she you know the lips on her face
she went up on her line
and forgot her line and then like blamed
me for it and the teachers wanted to
throw me out of school and it was a
whole big deal
um but yeah you're correct so do you
know who this is that we're talking to
right here joe i mean it's got to be
something in my class but i'm trying to
think of who's who's voice thing because
i'm i'm he doesn't
i'm a transformational actor joe
it's been a long time since i played
that other actor at the county fair
is
starved halo i think it ought to be
somebody in my class but i'm thinking
okay it's not you know i'm like it's not
boomer it's not you know i haven't i
haven't talked in a while so i'm trying
who is that public so i'm trying to look
him for the accent yeah he told us a
story that you propped your own damn
tooth out and carnegie mellon gotta get
it but he did not know
how you did it so it was a loaf of
french bread yeah how about that
you're a committed man i love you big
jokes my chicken brother yes man good to
hear your voice
all right i've got 90 seconds left so
how come you never asked pablo to play
dungeons and dragons with him oh
all right i would have i mean is this
pablo want to play dungeons and dragons
yeah you guys laugh it's not that
different from halo
it's true it's true
pablo pablo wants to see his buddy joe
but but but i'm not sure about the the
dozens of videos
just he said here's the deal you guys
can hang out just leave your 20-sided
diet home joe
all right rich i'm going to call you
with the time and you're going to come
over and we're going to get this thing
going i'll bring the french bread there
we go all right man take care of
yourself brother thanks good to see you
buddy there you go bringing people
together
that's what it is that was a reunion one
tooth at a time
that was fantastic i'm staying away from
entrepreneurs why are you guys bothering
me
what is going on
oh man okay so halo can be seen on
paramount plus starting today uh the man
who's bringing master chief to light
nailed it man who's upset that once
tyree kill was no longer a chief he
wasn't a jet oh pablo schreiber
everybody
that's all right we'll get another good
player
right
right is always the draft
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here